coach Prime's newest recruiter Colorado
has legendary blood in his veins from
two sports football and wrestling beat
Gage Goldberg son of WWE legend Goldberg
he committed to play linebacker for
Coach Prime in Colorado in early January
but it's not about the big lights that
now come with playing and Boulder that
swayed his decision Gage had
opportunities to play at Big schools
like Alabama Duke and UCF and originally
planned to commit to the tide but after
Nick sa retired and some advice from his
pops he just wanted the best fit
Goldberg was a dog at Georgia and later
for the Atlanta Falcons he was teammates
with Deion Sanders and formed a
Brotherhood and if anybody had beef with
Dion they had beef with Goldberg he told
Gage to pick the right school and the
one you know you'll love leading Gage to
admit that he already knows he would
love Colorado and thinks it's dopee to
play for one of his dad's best friends
Gage was a tackling machine for Champion
High School racking up 154 tackles and
forcing four fumbles his senior year
leading to him landing on Coach Prime's
radar now at Colorado Gage has the
chance to carve out his own Legacy by
making plays that hype up the crowd like
his father once did on the field and in
arenas